Noi siamo
Allora ragazzi non pensavo che ci
saremmo arrivati integri ma siamo giunti
alla fine cioè l'entusiasmo Allora
ragazzi non pensavo che ci saremmo
arrivati integri ma siamo giunti
all'ultima puntata di feroci No abbiamo
parlato con 10 ospiti tutti diversi tra
loro e ognuno con un proprio modo di
vedere la vita e di prendere la morsi
che fosse il corpo il vestito la mente o
l'anima che fosse la parola il desiderio
il vizio o la propria capacità di
ripartire da zero al centro del nostro
viaggio c'è sempre stato l'essere umano
in quest'ultima puntata però vogliamo
salutarvi ribaltando un po' la
prospettiva perché quando ci diamo la
possibilità di andare oltre il perimetro
della nostra cartina scopriamo che
esiste un universo intero che è sulla
dalla nostra volontà danza E convive con
se stesso Indipendentemente dalle nostre
azioni Allora ragazzi oggi incontriamo
Adrian fartade professione divulgatore
scientifico che si occupa di astronomia
e astronautica scritto infatti tre saggi
legati al tema dello spazio nel 2009 ha
creato la piattaforma web Link to
Universe dove si occupa delle più
recenti scoperte nel campo astronomico
dello sviluppo del mondo
dell'astronautico ha tenuto numerosi
monologhi sull'esplorazione spaziale in
diverse scuole e Teatri italiani dal
2022 nel programma di drusilla
l’almanacco del giorno dopo nella
rubrica l'astronomo del giorno dopo e in
tutto questo in realtà però è laureato
in a Siena in storia e filosofia Io
direi di iniziare a questo punto e di
far entrare Adrian no yes entri l'ultimo
ospite Adrian Hey Grazie
il nostro gran finale arriva sempre il
dolcissimo Allora io la prima domanda la
vorrei fare io posso ma devi grazie E
com'è nata la tua passione Allora in
realtà La cosa buffa è che non lo so
neanch'io Io mi ricordo più che altro
momenti in cui me ne sono accorto era
legato anche al fare teatro era una cosa
che facevo di continuo Eh non riuscivano
a farmi stare fermo quando ero anche
all'asilo c'è stato un momento in cui
erano tantissime perché ci hanno
lasciato giocare era un tornate le
insegnanti ed ero sopra un tavolo con
tutti i bambini intorno a cui io davo
ruoli dicevo tu prima il mago tu farei
il guerriero tu farei la principessa
eccetera le cose che assumono da quello
che vedevo cartoni animati e reinventavo
storie di continuo e quindi quando ho
incontrato storie che riguardavano la
scienza l'astronomia per me era
semplicemente una delle storie più belle
più fantastiche che abbiamo scoperto
Allora ehm Volevo chiederti una cosa
posso fare una domanda prego Allora noi
viviamo una realtà molto umanocentrica e
abbiamo fatto anche una trasmissione
molto umano centrica molto legata
all'essere umano e se dobbiamo un attimo
fare un passo indietro in realtà forse
un passo in su verso il cielo e guardare
tutto quello che circonda l'essere umano
e quello che è l'universo quindi quella
roba molto più grande di lui e gli
faccio forse la domanda più difficile
perché esiste hai solo 10 secondi per
rispondere aspetta
perché sono tanti di domande Non abbiamo
idea la risposta più bella per me è che
per quanto noi sappiamo come funzionano
tante cose nell'universo ancora davvero
Non abbiamo idea del perché esistiamo ma
anche a un livello proprio elementare
perché nell'universo sappiamo che ci
sono anche
anti-particelle per esempio Noi siamo
fatti di materia Ma esiste una
controparte della materia chiamata
antimateria che è uguale alla materia
solo con un segno opposto è come
Immagina due guanti uno e non te lo puoi
mettere sulla mano opposta giusto perché
semplicemente specchiato quindi per il
l'elettrone che nel nel caso della
materia è una particella con segno
negativo una carica negativa di avere
positivo Sì e sono i positroni Solo che
se tu fai incontrare una particella di
materia è una di antimateria si
trasformano appena si sfiorano in
energia e basta quindi sia nichiliscono
completamente ti basterebbe qualcosa
delle dimensioni di un palazzo per
distruggere completamente l'intero
pianeta Terra
tesoro dell'umanità Grazie
senza saperlo appena arrivato volevo
mettermi a favore preferito
la cosa bella dell'antibatteria in
realtà non è solo Quanta energia può
liberare Ma che sappiamo da modelli che
abbiamo riguardo all'universo e che
quando è iniziato l'universo subito dopo
il big bang doveva essere nata tanti ma
tanta materia quanto antimateria
esattamente e sappiamo che dovevano
anche lì stai facendo quindi l'Inter un
universo due devono passare nemmeno
Nemmeno partiva che era il gioco solo
energia non dovevano esserci cose fatte
di materia Invece quando guardiamo
intorno alle l'universo non c'è
antimateria quasi per niente sulla terra
riusciamo a crearla qualche volta nasce
qua e là ma sparisce subito e non
abbiamo idea del perché siamo qui
domanda Ma quindi se io avessi
dell'antimateria Diciamo che è la
controparte perfetta di questo bicchiere
li faccio toccare questo scompare
scompare credo buona parte dell'Italia
No vabbè sì la quantità di energia che
libereresti con altri materiali non è
non c'è non c'è niente là fuori che
rilascia così tanta energia quanto
lamento perché è letteralmente la
materia antimateria si trasformano solo
in energia e stiamo cercando di creare
motori che vanno ad antimateria perché
ti basterebbero poche gocce per avere
una navicella che è in grado di
accelerare così tanto per portarci verso
altre stelle
di Dio Che differenza con l'antimateria
la particella di Dio ma io questa cosa
me la ricordo non so se voi leggeva tipo
Mangili e Demoni tipo quella roba lì che
alla materia era chiamato anche
particella di Dio Però magari era
un'approssimazione riguardava un'altra
cosa che non non sappiamo come perché
alcune particelle hanno massa e di cioè
è una approssimazione che questa Però in
pratica le particelle non sono tutte
uguali ci sono alcune che hanno pesano
di più di altre elementari e non abbiamo
idea di perché sono queste
caratteristiche una delle idee era che
quando viaggio Quando si muovono
All'interno dello spazio incontrano
immagina un campo di neve se Michele
cammina in mezzo alla neve la neve Alta
lui ha solo le scarpe normali potrebbe
camminare molto piano perché le scarpe
sprofondo all'interno Immagina se però
ha delle racchette sopra riesce a vedere
gli sci scivola sopra giusto e quindi
alcune particelle è come se passassero
all'interno di questo campo con più
fatica e quindi è come se avessero più
massa si muovono più lentamente altre
invece sono molto più leggere perché
interagiscono meno e noi stavamo
cercando di capire se esiste uno questo
campo chiamato capo di X e che cercavamo
un fiocco di neve per confermare che
esiste tutta la neve all'interno di cui
si muovono le particelle era chiamata
particella di Dio ehm perché L'idea era
che se troviamo questa piccola
particella di questo campo veramente
su cui si muovono tutte le particelle
riusciamo a spiegare perché alcune hanno
delle caratteristiche diverse da altre
In che senso le particelle hanno
caratteristiche Cioè Cosa si intende per
particelle innanzitutto se se prendiamo
lui e lo tagliamo in due con suo
consenso ovviamente però Possiamo
provarlo proprio Secondo me questo
Qualcuno ha un coltello ragazzi Lo
tagliamo in due e poi in due in due in
due ancora a un certo punto secondo i
greci e arriviamo
divisibili poi abbiamo scoperto che in
realtà anche quelli poi di taglia a
pezzi e trovi parcheggiare più piccole
come protoni e neutroni e poi se vai
ancora sotto trovi altre particelle
ancora più piccole dei prodotti dentro i
Quark che sono quello di cui hai fatto
un protone a un certo punto però sono
invisibili e le caratteristiche che
hanno quelle più piccole più invisibili
Non abbiamo idea da dove l'hanno presa
cioè perché sono così faccio un secondo
un salto indietro perché comunque tutto
il tuo lavoro tutta la tua ricerca parte
dal domande veramente enormi tutti i
ricordi la prima domanda enorme che ti
sei fatto Io mi ricordo quando da
ragazzino non so se voi lo facevate Ma
io mi stendevo sul Lui abita a guardare
il cielo e mi chiedevo certo
Cosa cazzo ridi Lollo è una cosa di una
profondità
che ti faceva il verso ma ero serio io
l'ho fatto No torniamo un secondo ad
Adrian Qual è la prima domanda enorme mi
ricordo che quando ero molto piccolo mi
chiedevo continuamente come è fatta la
Luna dall'altra parte c'hanno già le
foto solo che nessuno ehm non lo sapeva
e quindi quando chiedevo foto della luna
tutti mi facevano semplicemente vedere i
libri dove c'erano delle foto della luna
ma visto Da questo lato guardavo le
stelle anch'io ehm spesso mi chiedevo se
eravamo soli se c'erano alieni là fuori
ma non tanto per la curiosità per gli
alieni Ma solo perché mi chiedevo in
realtà se c'era qualcun altro che si
sentiva solo ero molto solo Durante
l'infanzia per tante aspetti e quindi il
fatto che c'era qualcun altro là fuori
che poteva guardare le stelle allo
stesso modo e non so era Era un pensiero
che era Dolce Amaro allo stesso tempo
Pensa che la cosa fighissima del tuo
lavoro è che comunque si parte da che è
un po' cioè ehm nella musica succede un
po' la stessa cosa in maniera traslata
però si parte da un concetto di
solitudine Dove sono le soluzioni o
inizia a guardare in altro e scoprire
che sei piccolissimo o inizio a guardare
dentro e scoprire che sei ancora più
piccolo Perché arrivi al Quark e quindi
per me è una un'indagine sulla
solitudine è fighissimo allo stesso
tempo La cosa che mi ha sempre colpito
guardando il cielo è che quando quando
vedi per esempio la luce delle stelle
nasce dalla fusione nucleare al centro
delle stelle quindi atomi si fondono
insieme per formare altri miei più
grandi questo libera energia è tutta
quella quella Quella quella formula che
tutti si stampano intorno con scritto è
uguale a mc²
vuol dire che l'energia è Massa possono
essere intercambiabili per cui Oddio
quella formula ce la spieghi Lollo Un
secondo Ah non hai idea copiavo sempre
le verifiche di fisica ragazzi sta in
school non copiate Ma ti ricordi di chi
è Ah non era Einstein sì vedi Ah hai la
E perché
eh eh
io posso sopportare tutto su Instagram è
una grandissima stronzata io è un gioco
ragazzi
significa solo che la luce che noi
vediamo dalle stelle proviene dal
letteralmente pezzi di atomi che si sono
Fusi Quindi quando hai due atomics se
hanno Massa uno e uno si fondono insieme
la massa finale della nuova particella
non è due uno è qualcosa perché un po'
della massa viene solo trasformata in
energia Questo significa che poi quegli
quei fotoni che passano attraverso i
vari strati della stella e ci mettono
centinaia di migliaia di anni per uscire
perché la stella estremamente densa
Quindi rimbalzano da una parte all'altra
finalmente escono dalla Stella viaggiano
attraverso l'universo passando
attraverso nebulose sistemi planetari di
tutti i tipi finiscono per passare
attraverso tutto il sistema solare tutti
i pianeti arrivano fino a qui passano
attraverso tutta la tua sfera e
colpiscono la tua Torre il tuo occhio
che stai guardando le stelle e stimolano
i nervi all'interno del tuo nervo ottico
e quindi quello si traduce in quella
luce che vedi Ma quella energia ora fa
parte di te significa anche tu hai
letteralmente un pezzo della stella
fisicamente proprio dentro di te c'è un
energia che era l'equivalente di massa
Quindi hai portato via un pezzo della
stella che ora fa parte di te non c'è
questa qui è la cosa più poetica che
abbia mai sentito nella mia intera vita
e posso dire non esiste album di Michele
Bravi che è riuscito a darmi qualsiasi
sensazione
Ti prego Scrivici qualcosa con le stelle
negli occhi letteralmente Sì posso fare
un'altra domanda delle mie complicate eh
prego chiedo prima il permesso ai miei
colleghi Ma ti prego
adesso anche voi certo Ok allora non so
se questa domanda parte da una base
scientifica e qua Mi devi correggere
perché è solo una nozione di un romanzo
Cioè questo romanzo di Oriana Fallaci si
chiama inshallah allora eh la storia di
questo soldato che va in guerra un
soldato che prima di essere soldato era
un matematico ed era ossessionato dalla
formula dell'entropia che la formula di
Boltzmann si spiega che tutto è caos
fondamentalmente significa che per
esempio se tu prendi un contenitore
io ci metti delle palline blu da un lato
e delle palline rosse e dall'altra con
una divisione e mezzo per cui una
pallina può passare ogni tanto dalla
parte all'altra inizialmente sono molto
ordinate no Quindi sono rosse blu e
basta quella formula 1 dell'entropia
dice semplicemente che si aspetti
abbastanza tempo tutto quanto va nella
direzione del un po' e un po' Cioè se
aspetti abbastanza tempo qualche pallina
Rossa passerà di là qualche premio blu
di là fino a quando non ci saranno non
saranno mischiate a caso caos tutto
intorno l'intero Universo Tutto quanto
va solo in questa direzione il nostro
modo di percepire il tempo l'unico modo
che abbiamo per sapere che passa il
tempo e grazie all'entropia il fatto che
tutte le cose vanno verso quello che noi
chiamiamo appunto disordine in questo
caso ma mi attacca questa descrizione
del disordine Allora secondo il
personaggio della Fallaci se è tutto
disordine per lui disordine significa
morte allora dice qual è allora la
formula della vita qual è la formula
dell'ordine lui per tutto il romanzo
Cerca la formula della vita che è
secondo lui è il contrario della formula
di bozmann dell'entropia di bozza allora
ti chiedo Secondo te qual è la formula
della vita poi vi dico anche la risposta
che si danno il romanzo per me è la
stessa è la sempre sempre la stessa
formula perché in realtà wolfmann stesso
ne parlava per esempio ehm lui a
chiamava una cosa per i suoi colleghi
che ti mette il cervelli di Batman
lo potresti rispondere prima tu Allora
secondo me la formula della vita è caos
Ci sta però ehm non deve Ecco Ok
continuiamo ragazzi
in realtà ehm è proprio in virtù del
caos Perché l'universo è partito
estremamente organizzato perché era solo
tutto in un punto per cui se non ci
fosse stata l'entropia che ha spinto
l'universo a
cambiare in questo modo non avremmo
avuto stelle pianeti e quello che
vediamo ora è strano e contro intuitivo
pensare che il visto che tutto tende al
caos e disordine all'apparenza come fa a
esistere qualcosa che tende all'ordine
come la comparsa di esseri umani
semplicemente noi siamo un effetto
secondario temporaneo del caos noi
esistiamo Perché esiste il caos solo
finché il caos non vince su tutto e
quella sarà la fine dell'universo quindi
la Com'era la cosa carina la formula
della vita è riuscire a incastrarsi
all'interno del caos La cosa che mi
piace della vita è che noi sappiamo
benissimo che tutto andrà in quella
direzione e nonostante questo facciamo
morte Michele è la formula della vita
per me e il fatto che si fa aspettate si
può fare un cartello con la mia faccia
con scritto sotto la formula della
Michele Bravi la formula della vita
per favore
Guglielmo per te cos'è la formula della
vita Michele che approfondire mi ha
veramente rubato le parole di bocca io
ho un po' uno sguardo pessimista su
questa su questo tema noi non viviamo
ogni giorno noi moriamo mi rendo conto
che non è che sia proprio una botta di
di positività Se vuoi ti do la risposta
che ha dato la Fallaci Che cosa ci ha
detto lei riassume il concetto che dice
Adrian in realtà nello stesso modo ma
con una sola parola lei dice inscialla è
la formula della vita loro Questo
romanzo parla della Palla no eh in parla
della guerra in ira che inshallah vuol
dire sia fatto il volere di là e così
sia e per lei la formula della vita
significa accettare il caos cioè
accettare che anche il caos vince ehm
Okay ehm Okay è anche vero però che è
molto da noi non accettarlo cioè il
fatto che gli umani abbiano questa
spinta davanti a tutto quello che è
l'universo ci Lancia contro di trovare
in modo per andare oltre quando
l'universo ci ha messo davanti delle
montagne troppo alte Noi siamo andati
oltre che con le montagne quando messo
Mari davanti Abbiamo costruito barche
Abbiamo costruito aerei Razzi e quando
il sole porterà via ogni traccia di vita
sulla terra perché il sole continuerà ad
ingrandirsi piano piano e tra solo un
miliardo di anni non ci sarà più
speranza per niente sulla vita perché
oceani sarà un evaporati Noi siamo in
grado ora tecnologicamente di almeno
immaginarci di costruire mezzi per
andarcene da qui intorno ad altre stelle
nonostante Sappiamo benissimo appunto
che non abbiamo una vittoria in pugno
fino alla fine amo moltissimo nel senso
di lotta davanti a tutto questo perché
io sono cresciuto in una zona
estremamente Povera dovevamo forse un
pasto al giorno da mangiare abbiamo
paura di uscire per strada e in un
periodo storico incredibilmente
difficile e io crescevo come qui perché
io avevo scoperto alle elementari medie
di non essere binario e non sapevo come
vivere questa cosa e appena non so
prendevo per mano un altro ragazzo che
mi piaceva succede a finimondo per cui
per me riuscire a trovare lo spirito del
della speranza o anche di vedere gli
umani come indomabili davanti a
qualsiasi ostacolo mi ha dato la forza
quando guardavo là fuori
le stelle pensavo gli alieni se un
giorno li troveremo la mia più grande
speranza sarebbe arrivare il momento in
cui possiamo abbracciarci E poterci dire
quanto è incredibilmente difficile
essere senzienti avere questo senso
vuoto dentro che non riesce a riempire
con niente perché non hai idea del
perché Che senso ha essere senzienti mi
viene in mente eh le parole di una mia
amica che si chiama Chiara Gamberale lei
è una grandissima scrittrice lei a un
certo punto scrivo il libro Vabbè si
parla di tutt'altro il libro ma qualcosa
e parla di questo problema di questa
principessa che è un buco nel cuore e
lei non accetta questo vuoto è circa in
tutti i modi di riempirlo con qualcosa
ogni volta che lo riempie non c'entra
Non c'è spazio per accogliere le cose
mmm Allora lo deve risvuotare però
risente quel buco lì e a un certo punto
prende coscienza che quello non è un
buco ma è un passaggio segreto che la
porta da un'altra parte dove vi
porterebbe il vostro passaggio segreto
Lollo vai Ti vedo carico dove ti porta
il tuo passaggio segreto No io so per
chiederti poi ripetere la domanda No
perché fai queste domande così lunghe Eh
sono in realtà bellissime grandissime Io
in realtà questa ce l'ho questa ce l'ho
Ehm io credo che mi porta da me eh pare
brutto da dire ma la prima immagine mi è
venuta Allora io sono molto ossessionato
col concetto ovviamente della fine della
vita e compagnia bella però credo anche
quanto effettivamente Noi siamo diversi
rispetto a noi di 5 anni fa 10 anni fa
quindici anni fa per cui mi riporta in
realtà alla ricerca costante di un
qualcosa che io ho perso quando ero
bambino e che secondo me passo tutta
l'intera mia esistenza nel tentativo di
recuperare e quando lo faccio questo
pensiero penso anche che un lutto
personale cioè io purtroppo sono morto
tante volte per cui Mmm ti dico mi
riporterebbe da lui mi sembrerebbe da
tutti quanti quelle persone che hanno
fatto parte di me e che ho perso nel
tragitto scusa non so perché
per giudicare Allora in realtà io credo
che aggiungo un pezzettino alla visione
di Guglielmo mi riporterebbe
ahimè che ho lasciato indietro ma iMac
ha nascosto nelle persone della mia vita
Quando tu incontri qualcuno un po' come
quello che diceva prima Adriano No cioè
tu è come se impattassi con dei dei
pezzi di particelle che ti appartenga
Adesso lo dico malissimo Eh che però
Rimangono poi in quella persona e poi
sono persone che magari perdi Nel tuo
percorso
o che le perdi anche nella misura in cui
ti rimangono accanto perché volvono
insieme a te quindi quella loro versione
di prima non c'è più e quindi credo che
riverdrei tutti i pezzettini di me che
ho nascosto negli altri ladri la tocca a
te io in realtà sono molto d'accordo con
con Michele riguardo alla i pezzi in
altre persone mi piacerebbe tantissimo
scoprire quello che vedere altri hanno
visto di me che io non ho mai visto so
che le persone mi hanno visto con
soltanto sapendo soltanto un pezzo della
mia storia a volte sento un po' il peso
di sapere troppo di me e quindi è
faticoso vedermi come mi vedono gli
altri è uscire da questa dimensione
quindi ogni tanto mi piacerebbe potermi
vedere con la leggerezza con cui vedono
altri che non sanno tutta la mia vita
Certo Quindi sì mi piacerebbe tanto
vedermi bellissimi occhi leggeri di
altri Ecco io invece forse l'inverso
perché ancora non non
ho scoperto è pieno chi sono e quindi
forse ehm Mi piacerebbe vedere cioè
realmente
me quello che ho dentro e tu tutte le le
cose che ho dentro che ancora non ho
scoperto Bravo Lollo Io comunque ho una
sorpresa per voi anche Oddio sì
cioè che cos'è vi ho portato qualcosa
si vede sì Metti un dito metto un dito
così così è un pezzo della luna
non è vero davvero davvero quello è un
frammento della Luna di 4 miliardi di
anni fa e tutti quelli sono cristalli di
quarzi altri minerali che si sono
formati dopo continui impatti contro la
superficie lunare Cioè è toccare la luna
praticamente giusto Sì se tu fossi
Sailor Moon visto che sono cristalli di
Luna ti sarei già trasformato pazzesco
Peccato che non lo sei Avete tutti
presente Lollo tu hai presente la storia
di Orlando il furioso cioè il
furiosissimo Vabbè insomma c'è questo
passaggio dove si perde il senno della
ragione per colpa della madre comunque
questo personaggio va sulla luna perché
sulla luna ci sono nella parte non
visibile che era quella che tu no ti
dicevi da bambino Chissà come è fatta
ecco nella parte non visibile a un certo
tipo Eh ragazzi siete sempre preparati
giusto
e lui va lì per dire dove dove sta il
mio se Questa è la mia ragione per suo
ritornare in sé e io questa cosa vengo a
scoprirla Perché a un certo punto nella
mia vita ho avuto la fortuna di fare
delle lezioni con Ettore Scola Ettore
Scola è stato uno dei più grandi registi
del cinema italiano Vi ricordo che ci
aveva fatto tutta questa lezione sulla
luna per dire cercate di portarci le
cose perdute perché almeno lì sapete di
ritrovarle e quindi ci chiedeva tutte le
volte che cosa portereste oggi inizio io
Vai vai fallo fallo
tu butteresti cinderesti sulla luna No
mamma mia e quindi devo rimanere là
sulla Luna a far qualcosa e quindi la
missione sarebbe Apollo Barolo per
andare sulla luna
no no no no eh aliena ce l'hai tu mi
piacerebbe metterci le cose che ora
voglio di più i miei obiettivi perché so
che mi sto concentrando su degli
obiettivi molto tangibili grandi che
però so che non sono davvero quello che
mi porterebbero essere felice cioè sono
soltanto un modo per raggiungere uno dei
obiettivi che mi danno il senso di fare
qualcosa della vita cioè mi piacerebbe
non poter non pensare a questo il
distrarmi e non avere la necessità
voglia di inseguire degli obiettivi per
una volta cioè stare su quel Prato tutte
come da bambino e semplicemente chiedere
le cose sì quello che viene La Spezia è
molto bella come o come pensiero come
riflessione Ma io credo in realtà che
sulla luna sarò banale Eh io non ci
troverei mai oggetti ci troverei solo
persone quindi tendenzialmente Per
quanto mi riguarda io sulla luna ho già
un po' di persone che ho perso e che
vorrei rivedere perché io purtroppo ho
un bruttissimo terribile rapporto con
l'abbandono con il distacco con la
sensazione del stop mai più da adesso e
quindi anche con l'evoluzione del tempo
dell'essere umano il sapere per esempio
che il ragazzo del quale ero innamorato
cotto che per me è stato l'amore della
mia vita adesso non mi dica più nulla
quel ragazzo e anche quel Guglielmo che
si amavano in quel modo così forte Li
vorrei ritrovare sulla luna li vorrei
ritrovare persone che non ci sono più
sono un po' banale Scusate su questo
però è proprio l'unica cosa che mi sento
di dire io io aumenti cioè
vari momenti della mia vita che ho
vissuto che vorrei rivivere ma anche il
liceo Cioè è stato bellissimo per me Ero
proprio felice mi sentivo eh protetto
dai miei amici Cioè mi piaceva anche
avere l'ansia delle verifiche
l'ansia di di cosa avrei fatto nel
futuro cioè quest'ansia qua buona mi
piace a me sai che io invece la vedo al
negativo questa cosa cioè io sulla luna
forse se dovessi nasconderci qualcosa
per poi ritrovarla nel tempo ci metterei
tutta la cattiveria che possa avere
incontrato e qui magari ho anche fatto
agli altri per ritornare poi a vederla
domani con una consapevolezza diversa e
accettarla dovete sentire quel movimento
cattiveria nel mio scrotondo perché io
ho sentito che Michele riesce Io sono
stanco anche una profondità di Michele
Bravi sei stanco Io sono raso adesso non
puoi più fare domande se effettivamente
ne avevo altre Io comunque se ne hai
altre Eh hanno in mezzo racconti di
libri e cosa non è proprio fine ce n'è
un'altra torniamo torniamo
di tristezza solitudine abbandono ma va
bene così nascondo il mio dolore sulla
luna ci sono delle cose che vorremmo
tantissimo come umani ritrovare che
abbiamo lasciato lì inizialmente senza
pensare che vorremmo ritrovarli ma li
abbiamo lasciati proprio per non
ritrovarmene e invece ora abbiamo
cambiato idea le vogliamo tantissimo
quando gli umani sono andati lì hanno
lasciato dei sacchetti prima di andare
per alleggerire la navicella con tutto
quello che non serviva più e dentro che
i sacchetti c'erano tantissima cacca che
tantissima quindi giusto quantitativo di
cacca che non lo farei che di merda Oh
potevano essere Sparati spazio chili di
merda Allora diciamo che quando hai una
navicella che deve essere sottili Cioè
più sottile possibile per arrivare con
il minimo carburante necessario non vuoi
Avevo quel chili in più cioè un chilo di
merda in meno significa un po' più
spinta con la navicella e quindi se
sbagli qualcosa ti serve un pochino più
carburante Non immaginano non arrivare
arrivare tutto immagino non arrivare
all'incontro con la Norvegia che ti
porta a casa per una 3 secondi di
carburante e quei 3 secondi si fanno la
differenza perché le consumati per
portarti un tiro di merda ci rimane un
po' male quindi le abbiamo lasciate
l.o.l le abbiamo lasciate sulla luna
Okay e adesso invece li vogliamo troppo
Li vogliamo tantissimo perché sono pieni
erano ovviamente pieni anche di batteri
e di vita che è rimasta lì che è rimasta
nella cacca per 50 mezzo secolo più di
mezzo secolo e quindi quando ritorneremo
e potremo prendere dei Campioni potremmo
vedere come se l'è cavata la vita senza
protezione sulla luna per mezzo secolo
avanti c'è un'altra domanda
curiosità non è assurdo
Scusatemi madre chiedete ma mi lasciate
sfogare questo è sempre stato contenuto
Allora per questo mi tolgo anche gli
occhiali e vabbè Eh Dov'è nato
l'Universo
[Musica]
raga è l'unica domanda che abbiamo già
fatto Secondo te dov'è il centro
dell'universo Allora io farei un calcolo
e analizzerei quali sono i pianeti che
vanno da una parte quelli che vanno
dall'altra parte cercando di capire qual
è il punto da cui tutti fuggono la cosa
meravigliosa È che l'abbiamo fatto E
ogni punto è il centro dell'universo
perché tutto quanto si allontana tra di
sé in tutte le direzioni Cosa significa
che
è il centro dell'universo ma anche anche
te Anche perché le chiunque qualsiasi
persona può guardarsi allo specchio la
mattina e a pensare tutto quanto
Oppure puoi vederla in modo apposta e
pensare Tutto l'universo si allontana da
me letteralmente qualsiasi Galassia si
allontana in tutte le direzioni lontano
da me da lì che sappiamo che l'universo
è iniziato con un punto tutto Esatto ma
questa cosa qui del punto Sì eravamo Sì
tutti quanti Un punto energetico punto
esplodere super super Come si dice
ordinato ma torno ci devo essere stato
il delirio non c'era niente Non esiste
attorno perché tutto quello che c'è
l'intero esistenza tutto tutto tutto era
in un solo punto ma non c'era nulla
intorno ho capito non esiste nessuno si
è fatto una domanda tipo o delle teorie
su perché c'era questo Bozzolo di merda
pronto esplodere e lanciare feci ovunque
non è neanche solo esploso ha lanciato
cioè semplicemente ehm ha iniziato a
espandersi quindi le distanze tra ehm
all'interno e le distanze hanno iniziato
ad aumentare quindi il punto in sé si
espande ma non c'è non c'è un'esplosione
non è che si muove in qualcosa non c'è
un centro immagina di essere un disegno
due dimensionale va bene sulla
superficie di un palloncino che gonfi ne
aggiungo un centro del palloncino giusto
della superficie la superficie vado
tutte le parti lunghe e non c'è non c'è
nulla fuori in due dimensioni quello è
il tuo intero universo non esiste una
terza dimensione in questa metafora per
cui per noi è lo stesso con l'universo
non c'è per quello che sappiamo al
momento un fuori dall'universo
l'universo si espande in se stesso
potrebbe essere finito e senza confini
Oppure potrebbe essere finito Non lo
sappiamo uno scienziato non incuriosisce
nel momento in cui pensa ma che cosa
c'era un secondo prima che quel il tempo
ha iniziato a scorrere da quel momento
per cui è un po' Come andare al Polo
Nord geografico e chiedersi cosa c'è più
a nord possiamo ipotizzare quello sì
l'universo noi sappiamo che aumenterà la
velocità delle espansioni sempre di più
a un certo punto l'energia necessaria
per aumentare l'espansione sarà così
alta che potrebbe essere
sufficientemente alta da creare una
nuova espansione Quindi praticamente
l'intero Universo diventerebbe un nuovo
Big Bang tra virgolette quindi può
essere che semplicemente l'universo crea
altri universi continuamente hai
presente i ehm i frattali i frattali sì
e gli alberi come crescono che c'è un
ramo e poi ah ah okay okay okay okay
quello e quindi l'universo potrebbe
espandersi continuamente i nuovi
universi così in per sempre ma noi non
sapremo mai No Qual è sì c'è stato una
mano che poi detto espanditi se anche ci
fosse una forza esterna che
risultato l'inizio di tutto quanto Chi
ha fatto iniziare lui devi a un certo
punto premettere partire dall'idea che
c'è qualcosa a prescindere sì e a
prescindere Cioè chi è all'inizio di Dio
a quel punto esatto Chi ha fatto Dio ma
non ti viene il mal di testa a farti
queste domande tutto il giorno con la
tua ricerca è molto legato anche a cose
umane per cui ci trovo un sacco di cose
divertenti di mezzo per esempio nel
prima si parlava dell'entropia no se se
tu aspetti per abbastanza tempo è vero
che tutto tende al disordine ma in
realtà non è proprio il disordine e
potenziale se giochi a scrable hai tutte
le Come si chiama Scarabeo Eh hai tutte
le parole già organizzate sul tavolo no
E l'universo quello che vuole Non è
disordine vuole potenzialità di creare
nuove cose andando avanti l'universo
semplicemente mette lettera a caso e
quindi è vero che se tu metti lettera a
caso sulla superficie di questa tavola
da fuori per noi sembra disordine ma se
aspetti però abbastanza tempo tutte le
combinazioni succederanno non c'è niente
nell'universo che proibisce che se io
tengo la mano ora così qui compaiono una
torta il realmente Non succederà mai
prestare tutto il tempo con la mano così
mi occuperà mai una torta però
matematicamente
Se aspetti un infinità di tempo prima o
poi succederà Scusate salto proprio da
tutt'altra parte però perché è una cosa
che a me Ehm Manda ai matti la coscienza
è fortemente legata al cervello per
quella che è la mia esperienza Sì ma la
fine è la morte cerebrale coincide per
forza Secondo la scienza con la fine di
una possibile coscienza personale o
qualcosa di simile sì Ehm quello che noi
sappiamo di quello che la coscienza e
che è un prodotto secondario
dell'attività della neocorteccia
cerebrale e si è evoluta perché ci serve
per avere una cognizione migliore di noi
dell'ambiente intorno e anche perché noi
come specie abbiamo bisogno sia di
lavorare in gruppo e quindi abbiamo
bisogno di una società Maggiore ma anche
di pensare in astratto alle nostre
necessità sul lungo termine Questa è una
spiegazione super superfici perché ci
sono dibattiti enormi e francamente
nessuno lo sa di preciso che cos'è la
coscienza perché è questa spiegazione
funziona in base alla tua definizione in
base a come Definisci Che cos'è
coscienza noi tradizionalmente nella
filosofia occidentale specialmente
perché già in Oriente è diverso però
abbiamo legato tantissimo l'idea di
coscienza solo con il nostro cervello e
la mente il nostro corpo è solo tipo un
involucro che porta la mente in giro
invece in tradizioni diverse per esempio
già in Oriente trovi lunghe tradizioni
in cui il corpo la sensazione che tu hai
del corpo dell'esperienza che hai del
mondo fa parte della costruzione della
coscienza e della consapevolezza e già
potrebbe cambiare definizione No
purtroppo poi non era voluto però
recentemente una persona che veniva
veniva fatto dei test per le pile che
sia è morta durante delle ehgi che sono
elettroence programmi e molto mentre era
sotto la macchina e abbiamo visto
l'attività del cervello decine di
secondi prima della morte durante la
morte dopo la morte abbiamo visto che
cosa fa il cervello Mentre una persona
muore Quali sono le zone che si
accendono quali si spengono la zona che
sembra
accendersi tantissimo nel momento della
morte e quella collegata a o attività di
sogni oppure la memoria e riportare a
memoria le cose quella sembra attivarsi
tantissimo nel momento della morte Non
abbiamo idea se questa cosa Però lui
l'ha vissuta Perché sembra è facile dire
Ah ok Quindi quella cosa del ti passa la
vita davanti agli occhi È vera non
sappiamo se lui era cocente o che cosa
vedevano eh puoi vedere solo Qual è il
cervello si illuminava poi è così in
tutte le persone era lui l'eccezione
quindi non è molto scientifico di in
senso stretto però è un possibile
indizio che magari davvero nel momento
della morte il tuo cervello come ultima
cosa ti lancia le immagini dei tuoi
ricordi più intensi della tua vita e la
percezione del tempo potrebbe essere
estremamente dilatata colleghi mi
concedete l'ultima domanda eh Ti prego
questa bella
[Musica]
tutto questo racconto di incertezza che
ci fai qual è il senso dell'esistenza
Allora oh È bellissima questa è una
delle mie domande preferite Ecco perché
penso che sia estremamente bello Ehm
potersi dare un senso perché non c'è già
e questa seconda delle cose belle per
esempio l'autunno scorso a un certo
punto erano nel parco e c'era un mucchio
di foglie gigantesche mi sono lanciato a
Stella e era molto divertente era molto
stupido come come gesto però ho
ritrovato diciamo quel senso di anche
che avevo rivisto quella crescendo e il
fatto che la la vita non è fatta per
avere un obiettivo in sé non vai da
nessuna parte ci sei già tutto quanto
inventato tutto quanto l'abbiamo
costruito per sentirci meno soli e per
cercare di darci una ragione e ritrovare
quei momenti di ehm godersi quello che
succede senza pensare che devi andare a
qualche parte per me è bellissimo poi mi
riporta anche a il fatto che il senso
stesso della vita non è universale non è
qualcosa che trovi nessuno dovrebbe
prenderlo da dogmi o da qualcun altro
che l'ha già costruito perché sennò
diventa un po' Come ritrovare un fuoco
fatto da qualcuno in un bosco e
riscaldarti lì e può essere
tranquillizzante sul momento ma poi
prima o poi pioverà prima o poi il fuoco
si spegne e se tu non hai fatto il
processo per trovarti quel senso della
vita non hai imparato ad accendere tu il
fuoco e il fuoco il senso che ti dai a
volte smetterà di avere senso perché
appunto succedono cose nella vita perdi
di persone care succedono cose terribili
Ma se tu hai fatto quel processo sai
sempre come Riaccendere il fuoco sei
sempre dove c'è un mucchio di foglie in
cui lanciarti per ritrovare perché sei
vivo e penso che per quanto difficile
possa essere da un momento all'altro per
quanto facile sia perdere il senso della
vita la cosa più bella degli umani non è
vera il senso della vita ma il fatto che
siamo costruttori siamo tessitori
abbiamo tessuto su di noi un senso
l'universo non ce l'ha dato non c'è
nessun motivo per cui non dobbiamo
averlo siamo su un piccolo pallino in
mezzo al niente e non c'è niente intorno
a nessuno a cui frega niente se
esistiamo o no se scompariamo domani ma
noi nonostante tutto siamo una specie
che si è cucita addosso un bellissimo
senso della vita e non uno ma miliardi
nel tempo ogni persona si cucita una
cosa unica che ti per me questo è il
senso più bello è che ogni persona
durante la sua vita si crea un senso
intorno Adriana mamma mia io non mi
potevo immaginare in chiusura più bella
migliore bellissima grazie davvero
Grazie di cuore per essere stato nostro
ospite per averci permesso di chiudere
veramente alla grande
porto via la luna Voglio trovare un
senso con questa vita anche se questa
vita
Un senso non ce l'ha Voglio trovare
un senso a questa situazione
Anche se questa situazione
un senso non ce l'ha Ok
allora Ragazzi sentite per 11 puntate
abbiamo cercato di dipingere un affresco
irregolare atipico ma il più Fedele
possibile a quelli che sono alcuni
aspetti dell'essere umano abbiamo avuto
ospiti eterogenei e diversi che ci
permettessero proprio di tratteggiare
temi diversi a volte distanti tra loro
talvolta invisibili o persino
controversi il nostro compito non è mai
stato quello di spiegare nulla a nessuno
ma se mai di raccontare fermare una
serie di punti che ognuno di noi potesse
coltivare approfondire e unire da solo
quella del viaggio esperienza personale
il massimo che possiamo sperare di aver
fatto per voi è quello di essere stati
dei compagni sopportabili Per quanto mi
riguarda Michele Lollo voi siete stati
non Preziosi di più non vi ringrazierò
mai abbastanza per aver deciso di
percorrere insieme a me questo viaggio
Ti rendi conto che stai facendo dei
ringraziamenti leggendo spudoratamente
un copione c'è scritto Eh no no no no no
no no no no no no mi dispiace Io posso
ringraziarmi da solo no no no no no no
no Voi siete stati Preziosi non vi
ringrazierò mai abbastanza per aver
deciso di percorrere insomma questo
viaggio Io posso dirti una cosa Eh è
molto triste che è proprio un cantante
che scrive le sue emozioni e che quindi
le Pianifica prima per poi poterle
raccontare dopo mi venga a fare un
discorso simile ti sei tolto la corona
proprio nel nell'ultimo minuto non è
pianificato questo è togliersi l'anima
io ho io ho semplicemente in un momento
nemmeno volevo farlo però poi No vabbè
ci sta perché me la sentivo capito Mi
sentivo di volerlo scrivere quindi ho
catturato quel momento perché io non
sono bravo nella stessa cattura io e
Lollo adesso tra 3 2 1 ti diremo prego
prego
dai ragazzi veramente siete stati mega
carini possiamo dirlo un'ultima volta
tutti insieme seppellendo questa ascia
veramente
una domanda da farti Michele
è questo il modo in cui tu vuoi che io
ti ricordi Sì
ti posso suggerire una cosa No questo
atteggiamento non ho bisogno sulla luna
così che 80 anni dopo arrivederci in
maniera diversa Okay perché per il
momento è negativo
Lollo È il mio preferito dopo [ __ ]
[ __ ] allora dai lo facciamo
insieme tutti ma ce lo dividiamo un
pezzettino per uno aspetta Mi dai gli
occhiali
€20 aspetta per il saluto finale ho
bisogno anch'io dei miei occhiali Certo
immagino da noi feroci è tutto ragazzi e
ragazze un graffio
Che merda che è stato finalmente finita
questa roba Mamma mia
chiamatemi un taxi
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]